Husband hasn't had a sausage Egg Mcmuffin in a very long time.
When he mentioned it the other day,
I knew I had to make it for him for breakfast today.
So I got started on making my English muffins,
combining some flour and salt
and then adding some eggs to my yeast mixture.
While my Kitchenaid was going,
I poured in some butter.
After about eight minutes,
I transferred it over to a different bowl so it could rise.
Next up, we're making the sausage,
so I combine some pork and ground beef.
I added all of my seasonings,
which were some fennel seeds,
Calabrian chili,
and other things,
before sprinkling it with some parsley and let that sit in the fridge.
Got started on making some spicy ketchup.
Combined all of my ingredients in a saucepan
and let that simmer on low for about 20 ish minutes.
Once it got thick,
adjusted my seasoning and then let that cool as well.
By this time, I checked on my dough and it had doubled in size,
so I transferred it over to a floured work surface
and just pressed it down.
Then use little cookie cutter molds to get them in circles.
I made some bigger and some smaller just to see what I preferred.
So I cooked off my bigger ones first.
Once they were golden brown on one side,
I flipped them over, and once everything was done cooking,
I transferred it over to my wooden plate.
I formed my sausage into little patties
and dried them off until they were nice and crisp
before moving on to my egg.
Look, he's very specific with his eggs,
so he took over,
did it the way that he wanted to,
and then we assembled down some white cheddar,
the breakfast sausage,
egg, micro greens,
and there we go.
Look, he added some of the spicy ketchup with it.
Obviously need a runny yolk.
He had five more after this,
so I'm assuming he really enjoyed them.